c'est aussi pour cette raison que le
deuxième objectif que je souhaite nous
assigner collectivement c'est celui de
la responsabilité les corps
intermédiaires public liszt économiques
et sociaux ont parfois été décrié en ce
qu'il pouvait avoir de corporatiste ou
de conservateurs ce n'est pas mon
opinion je crois pour ma part au sursaut
du moment présent et au sens de la
responsabilité de chacun nous savons
tous ce temps que traverse notre pays
je n'oublie rien des conditions qui
m'ont conduit à cette place
le doute est elle a un autre projet pour
la nation était présente et proposer aux
français et a manqué de l'emporter une
colère une impatience et là qui chaque
jour nous rappelle ce devoir est pensé
parce qu'une nouvelle année s'ouvre que
nous pourrions retrouver en quelque
sorte d habitude et que les grands
changements ne valent que pour les
années électorales se serait décidé de
ne pas être à la hauteur de l'histoire
notre pays est pleinement conscient des
grands changements qu'il a à vivre notre
pays est profondément conscient que les
défis qui sont les siens aujourd'hui
qu'il s'agisse des défis économiques et
sociaux migratoire moreau parfois
civilisationnel environnementaux
traversent toutes nos politiques
publiques sont là qui impose de
transformer en profondeur notre action
publique de repenser les fondamentaux
celle ci est de garder le même niveau
d'ambition la même intensité
notre responsabilité c'est de ne rien
lâcher de l'effort et la passion qui
nous guide et de la nécessaire
transformation que nous devons
poursuivre